as the cdc loosens
social distancing guidelines for schools
and most districts reopen classrooms
a new survey finds 59 percent of
students now have the option of
in-person learning for our series school
matters we visited parsippany hills high
school
in new jersey to follow up with a group
of high school educators
we first met eight months ago pedro
hernandez teaches social studies there
sheena graham is a music and chorus
instructor in bridgeport connecticut
emily krieger teaches health in new york
state and matt baker teaches math
in new york city all four are partially
or fully vaccinated they are currently
teaching students
on hybrid schedules and have more
students coming back in person
after spring break how are you all doing
everybody laughs emily stark
emily i'm okay i think i'm better now
than i was if you asked me probably
four or five months ago man
just tired i'm just like epically
permanently tired at this point
sheena i'm glad to be here yeah
i um this has been a journey it's
it's a little overwhelming still yeah
just dealing with
going from being heroes to villains in a
short period of time
pedro how are you doing i'd say i i
adjusted
but i'll tell my kids like sometimes
it'll come out
i hate virtual teaching or at least just
you know remote teaching for the kids
that i have at home
that i just want everyone back in the
classroom because it's just
just a better experience for me and the
kids speaking of
the kids how would you say your kids are
doing
one student said to me are you as afraid
to be around me as i am to be around you
really they take in a lot and if you've
really built relationships with students
this is a stressful time for them being
near you
when they care about you for me i've
really focused on
like shayna said the relationship
building which i do
but i really spend a lot more time in
investing in that because they need
somebody and they need somebody to lean
on
i think the kids have had a year of
trauma that they've been working through
and i think we're trying as best as
we can to address their trauma and help
them
process it from a distance when but when
the teachers are going through trauma
too
also like we just don't have the
resources like
i still don't know what some of my
students look like i'm curious how you
feel
that you've been treated as teachers
through this whole period of time i'll
tell people i'm a teacher we know where
i go in conversation and
they applaud me they thank me and you
know i'm like
thank you but it doesn't really set him
because then there's the other side
where
you're the reason my kid's not back in
school we are working
our butts off every single day to make
sure kids are learning and kids are
working really hard
and then you hear these stories about
kids aren't learning anything and
schools are closed even though
it doesn't feel like we're closed
because i'm working all the time
and that's just it's been really
demoralizing
sometimes how much do you think this has
cost
the kids you teach academically
content wise it's hard um i'm
probably two or three weeks behind where
i was last year two or three weeks
behind yeah they're able to connect
things and i think that's
really one of the biggest parts of
history is being able to explain
and link these things together but even
then
all i'm seeing is ceiling and i have to
see all right uh whose lights are that
all right that's uh
you're seeing ceiling yes the cameras
are on but
i see a lot of ceilings or tapestry or
artwork behind
but i know who the kids are and if i
talk to them they'll respond
but it's just how much are they really
engaged do you think
standardized tests should should not be
given this year yes
yeah my takeaway from last year was we
went through three quarters of a year
normal shut down and we said you know
what
let's make everybody exempt let's not
give a regents exam
yeah and now you've asked us to reinvent
what we're doing in a classroom
asking students to handle remote in
person
and now we're saying hey and now we want
you to take a regents exam
i just don't see why are we doing them
to me it's
it's money those companies want to get
paid to you know distribute them
but you're not thinking about the
student right now the regents exams are
just going to show us what we already
know that this
pandemic has hit different communities
very differently
and i don't trust that they're going to
use that information to like make things
better
so much as make those kids lives harder
when we get back
not to mention taking the test when you
don't know half the stuff on the test is
traumatic for kids like yeah
all of us have memories of sitting down
for a test we didn't study for and
thinking that up please but like so true
but like it's it's going to be just
adding
unnecessary trauma to these kids who
know they're behind we know they're
behind
but here sit and take a three-hour exam
that shows you just how behind you are
yeah and you're setting kids up pretty
much to fail right now
as you look to the fall and the
likelihood that
everyone will be back in school how do
you feel
i think the concern would be
making sure that with the funding that
comes
the mental health people are going to be
there full
force and not just for the kids
for you too for us too i think that
and i i don't want to speak for anybody
here but i know
a lot of teachers who are were broken
with all the stress that this year has
brought
did any of you consider giving up
teaching
yes you did i did so there were days
where i thought you know
i'm not sure i can hold on you know you
find yourself
if i'm honest you cry a lot in the car
so how did you get through it and keep
doing it
this is embarrassing but i'm going to
tell you if you've ever seen the show
the office
[Music]
one of the characters dwight would go
out on sales calls
and he would sit in the car and head
bang
this was my first time in my life
becoming a headbanger i mean i
crank that music up and i'm just out
there going for quite a while
and it's like just i mean it sounds so
silly
but it's hard to do that and then get
out of the car and cry
and so it's like little little things
and so when you get those moments where
the kid
speaks from the heart and just says
you're making a difference that's what
helps you to hold on
and so i know my time's not up
thank you sheena graham for your honesty
and for to matt and to pedro and emily
to all of them for talking to us again
and and and you know how much they've
been through i mean i want to point out
that matt was talking to us
uh a day after the one year anniversary
that one of his fellow
teachers died of covet so he experienced
this very early on
and they've been through so much and
they've been so resilient
the residue is still you can feel it in
the room with them
did you tell all your teachers to wear
bright blue no i don't know what it's a
great picture
you're good at tv we'll be right back
you're watching cbs this morning